so i want to show you something that is
bringing me joy right now
because it is spring this little bird
nest
has a little egg in it that was me a few
months ago
that's crazy right after i discovered
this bird's nest with a single bright
blue egg sitting on
this porch swing a few days later it had
four eggs
guess what happened next they hatched
and you better believe i named them
this is goose pepper jack dot and rocco
for a few weeks when i was really bored
during lockdown i watched these little
baby birds grow
and grow and grow and i started to film
them
and they let me get really close i even
filmed them in slow motion
you'll find out later why as i watched
them grow
a million questions popped in my head
why is this egg blue how long do the
eggs take to happen what type of bird is
baby
but my biggest question how was this
tiny little nest
not full of poop
to answer all my questions i tracked
down this guy my name is michael murphy
i'm a professor
of biology at portland state university
in portland oregon
he's an ornithologist which means he
studies birds
my personal interest is in behavior of
birds
and the population biology of birds and
when he says birds he means
a lot of birds tree swallows barn
swallowers
lift swallows eastern phoebes spotted
towies
i've worked on a species known as the
eastern king bird since 1979
you can see i have a tattoo of the creek
there
he studies all of their behaviors like
where they sleep
what they eat and how they travel and he
also knows
a lot about bird poop which brings us
back to the eggs i found on my porch
so what type of birds are in these eggs
well that was an american robin
when it grows up it's got this fiery
orange belly it's impressive
this animal um breeds across an enormous
swath of north america
it travels as far north as alaska to
breed in the springtime
and as far south as mexico during the
cold winter months
that's over 5 000 miles it seems as long
as you've got
a structure it can put a nest on and as
long as it can get some good mud
to build a nest you're gonna find it so
it's just
extremely adaptable
so let's walk through the life of my
porch robins
first they're just four little eggs why
are they
blue well that's a big question
[Music]
the coloration of bird eggs is extremely
variable what we do know is that bird
eggs come in
all sizes and colors white eggs like
this giant ostrich egg have been around
for millions of years
over time the eggs just like the birds
themselves
have adapted to survive some are
speckled because they want to blend into
their environment
so do you see the three eggs in this
photo
look closer and for blue eggs
well the blue color is caused by a
pigment in the mother
it's the same pigment that makes bruises
turn blue
and some butterflies like this one have
bright blue in their wings
pigments also strengthen eggshells
so it's actually an active area of
research still trying to figure out
why birds eggs are blue
so the mother lays the bright blue eggs
and
the parents incubate those eggs it takes
about 14 days for them to
complete their development in the egg
and then they hatch out
and then they're going to spend roughly
12 days
more in the nest and over that
12-day period they as you saw in your
films
change enormously they go from a
non-flying
individual that is completely helpless
they're completely blind they have no
feathers except for a little down
they really look like aliens within 14
days
they are out of the nest instead of
little bald aliens they look like grumpy
old men
and within just a few more days they're
actually able to fly
not like an adult but they can fly
so what exactly happens in those two
weeks in the nest
i don't know if you've ever tried to
raise a baby bird
but it's it's just so time consuming
they just eat and process
food all day long watch this
dot goose rocco and pepper jack are deep
in sleep
but when they hear their parents come
they shoot right up
super fast they eat worms
bees caterpillars and flies and they
have to eat so much because they have to
grow so quickly
the selection to grow fast to get out of
the nest is probably mostly related to
the fact that
lots of things eat baby birds
therefore it's a dangerous point in
their life getting through that quickly
is important
now if i know one thing about babies
it's this
they eat they sleep and they poop
and it can get very messy but somehow
this nest is spotless so where on earth
does
all the poop go i recorded
hours upon hours of footage to figure
out exactly where this poop was going
because it seemed to just disappear into
thin air
and then i spotted it
turns out the hatchlings definitely poop
a whole lot
but they were pooping directly into
their parents mouth
and the parents were eating it
uh your your observation that the nest
is extremely clean
is very accurate and it's because they
have those
structures referred to as special sacks
they're basically like baby bird diapers
so
instead of bird poop making a huge mess
the fecal sacks keep it nice
and contained i mean it really looks
like a disposable thing
but the adults as you filmed they'll
wait
at the rim of the nest for that baby to
pick up that fecal sac the moment it
emerges from the body
now once the parent has the fecal sac
they do one of two things
if you've got young that are sedentary
and they're going to be
in one spot for days maybe even weeks
you don't want that getting too dirty so
sometimes the parents fly away with it
to drop it off somewhere else far away
from the nest
but in many cases the parents ate the
fecal sac
as i was watching your film they started
to get a little sick in my stomach after
oh yeah i know birds do this but after a
while you watch them do it
that many times oh man isn't that you
know
let's just throw them all away
one of the hypotheses as to why they eat
them
is that there is useful material
in the fecal sex and so it might behoove
the parents
since they're already working really
hard to keep those babies fed
to just eat them and capture the energy
and water that is still remaining in the
fecal sex
tasty not all birds do this
so this is an osprey nest what they do
instead
is the babies well when they're really
young they probably do poop in the last
little bit but as they get older
the youngsters position themselves when
they have to go
over at the edge of the nest they point
their butts out over the edge and then
they'll just
poop right off the edge of the nest the
world
is their toilet
[Music]
after 12 to 14 days growing in the nest
hatchlings start to get really crowded
here's a moment where goose literally
fell out the nest because he barely fit
don't worry goose made it back in
getting to that point
is rough because probably 60 percent of
nests fail
but this nest it made it the very last
piece of footage i captured was this
rocco just flew right off the porch
of those that do get out of the nest
they're gonna have to make it through to
their first year
and maybe only about 30 of them actually
survive
now they've got to begin the important
process of reproduction
basically in just one year the
hatchlings become parents
and the process starts all over again
what can birds teach us
hard work birds
are hard working individuals that's for
sure they can teach us about ourselves
but they can also teach us about the
world we live in what they are showing
us is how connected the world is
birds migrate huge distances and then
there are some species which literally
call the world
the world their home
increasingly as time goes on we study
them to preserve them
and to conserve them so i think they
really are showing us
that we have to take a large picture
view of the world
you